okay so now we've got a coach's corner
segment
about deloads and deloads are
i find them very interesting because i
think there's a lot of variation in
how people approach them um it's a
question i get a lot from my clients
when they first start working with me
is what a deloads look like how often
are we going to do them why do we do
them
and it's always cool to see different
perspectives of how people handle
deloads
in the process of programming for
themselves and for a client
so i really want to figure out how
greg approaches them first and then talk
a little bit about how
i do with my client so greg deloads
first of all
why bother so that's a good question and
i think there are
two potential different answers to it so
one
is just and and i think this is probably
the most the most reasonable reason to
like
program deloads like say you know six
weeks from now we are going to take a
deload
uh is just kind of as a prophylactic
just like a better safe than sorry type
thing
um you know because you try to write
training programs
that are going to be uh you know
reasonable
volumes intensities frequencies whatever
like
a training load that people can recover
from
but you know sometimes you get volume
too high
sometimes people have life stressors
going on that come up
out of nowhere and you know a training
program that should have been
appropriate that someone could recover
well from
you know now it's a little bit too much
and fatigue starts accumulating
and you know if it accumulates for
six months you might really run into
issues but if if it accumulates for a
handful of weeks
uh they might feel a little worn down
but they're probably going to be fine
so um if it's a situation
like that especially if you're just
putting like
a general program out there into the
world and you're just trusting that
people will do it and not [ __ ] it up
or you know sometimes with like a a
distance
coaching relationship where you know
it's not like in person coaching where
you're going to be seen and talking to
the person multiple times per week and
being able to get a good read on them
um you know it's not a bad idea
to program deloads every
depending on the person maybe every four
to eight weeks
just as a prophylactic like you're not
going to miss out on that much
by taking an easy week of training but
you know on the the non-negligible
chance that maybe they are
starting to accumulate a fair amount of
fatigue that's going to give you
a chance to knock that down make sure
they're
you know in a band of stress that they
can recover and adapt positively to
um so i think that is
i think the main reason for using
proactive deloads
then uh personally
i prefer in my own training reactive
deloads
where instead of saying i'm gonna deload
every six weeks no matter what
i say i'm going to train in such a way
that i think is appropriate try to match
my
training stress to my recovery capacity
and then if i [ __ ] that up i'll take a
deload
um so you know if things are going well
i'm sleeping well
i'm not making dumb decisions with my
training maybe i'm not going to deload
for a year at a time
uh or you know if i do deload it's just
to
you know taper for a meet or something
uh
but you know if [ __ ] hits the fan
work-wise
i have just a random week of insomnia
which happens from time to time
then it's like okay i'll do a deload
i didn't plan to do to do this d load
but i'm feeling worn down i'm feeling
fatigued
i need to deload i'll take a deload um
so yeah there's there's proactive and
reactive deloads i tend to favor
reactive deloads if you're coaching
yourself and you have
and you're decent with being honest with
yourself and listening to your body's
feedback
um or if it's like an
in-person coaching relationship where
you know you can communicate with the
person you're seeing them multiple
times per week you can kind of get a
vibe on like how they're moving how
they're feeling
um so in those situations i tend to
favor reactive deloads
certainly for just putting like a
general program out there in the world
where
you hope that people do it and don't
[ __ ] themselves up
or for a lot of like distance coaching
where
you you can get feedback but it's
probably not going to be
especially like the subjective feedback
of just like
just seeing the person and being able to
get a read on on how they're feeling
um i think that more proactive deloads
make more sense in those situations and
so
a deload are you pretty much always
using a one-week
duration or is that flexible it's
flexible
um so
[Music]
i don't know it depends um
[Music]
for reactive deloads it's just like
however long i need
generally it's like three days maybe oh
okay
i mean just because like dude unless
unless i did some really stupid [ __ ]
i should be able to recover from just
about anything in three days like that's
that's a long time
especially for someone who's you know
reasonably well trained
theoretically they have like repeated
bout effect
adaptations to their muscles and nervous
systems so
they're hopefully not going to be able
to get too [ __ ] up in the first place
um so yeah i mean generally
i think that for most people most of the
time
somewhere between three and five days is
probably sufficient
but also people i mean we live in a
world that runs on
a seven day week and so seven days isn't
that much more than three to five days
if you accidentally put
if you push your d-load two days longer
than you needed to push it
that's fine like you're that's probably
realistically one training session
and if you take one more easy training
session than you needed to
that doesn't cost you anything you know
um
so yeah i don't think i don't think
having week-long deloads is a bad idea
i don't i don't think it's generally
necessary um
but you know it's that's probably a good
better safe than sorry length of the
deload
and so when you do a deload
i've seen people kind of propose
different approaches to it some people
just don't train
some people drastically reduce their
volume some drastically
reduce their intensity what does a
d-load actually look like for you
so to me i think i think it's important
to keep the purpose of a d-load in mind
um and i'll note that a d load is
similar to a taper but it's not exactly
the same thing as a taper
uh it's you know certainly ideal
if you feel good at the end of a deload
and that also coincides with performing
better
because you're less fatigued but you
know
in general after a deload you're not
trying to hit
your best one rep maxes ever the first
session back from the d-load
so that differs from a taper
where you know you probably do
need to keep you know somewhat
reasonable loads
moving just so by the end of it you're
you're not
d trained and you're able to you know
put it put a good total on the platform
so with a d-load i think
again it it kind of depends on the
person
um and it kind of depends on why you're
taking the d-load in the first place
and it depends on how that individual
reacts to different
training stressors and so if
if it's someone who so like using myself
for example
uh intensity doesn't really bother me
like
just i think from doing bulgarian style
training for a while
like i can hit a one rep max and if
that's all i do in that session the next
day i'm gonna feel like i did nothing
um whereas like hitting a true max and
training may
really cause a lot of fatigue for
someone else but for me like if my
volume gets reasonably high
that [ __ ] me up and really really wears
me down whereas for other people they do
a bunch of volume and less intensity so
they could do more volume and that
wouldn't affect them as much
so it's going to kind of depend on what
training variable
causes the most subjective stress to
someone so for me
if i'm taking a d load that means volume
is going to come way down
generally intensity is going to come
down a little bit as well but for me the
most important variable is volume
for someone who is more affected by
intensity
but you know their their volume
capabilities are great
and higher volumes don't cause as much
fatigue for them
for them a deload is absolutely going to
involve a big reduction
in intensity and probably a little
reduction in volume as well but
intensity is the main variable you'd
want to make sure you bring down
and again if you just want like a middle
of the road approach
reducing both is fine um
you know something like dropping
intensity 15
20 and volume 30 to 50 percent
that's probably going to make for a
pretty decent deload for most people
are there any instances where you would
just take time completely off
so i i think the answer to that kind of
depends on practicality more than
anything else um
i don't think it's like quote unquote
optimal
theoretically to just take time
completely off of training
um but at the same time again it's like
and i i think it depends on like how
frequently you're doing it so for
example
if you're doing a program where you do
three weeks of training and then deload
on the fourth week
so like a 5-3-1-esque setup
you probably don't want to take a
quarter of your total training time
completely off of training yeah that's
probably not ideal
um but you know if you have a setup like
that and you
you know do like a more typical deload
or you know you drop volume
in intensity a little bit and so it's
basically like you have three hard weeks
and one easy week
and you do that for a few months and
then on the fifth month you're like
you know what i'm feeling kind of burned
out i've been seeing way too much of the
inside of a gym
i just want to take this week off that's
fine
you know like taking a week off of
training every
four months six months whatever like
that's that's not gonna be the end of
the world
so unless you're doing that like all the
time
i think it's probably fine um again
it's probably not like the best thing to
do it's not theoretically optimal
but as long as you know as long as
you're not
taking like a week off every month
you're probably gonna be okay
do you recall seeing any research i
could have sworn i saw at least one
paper like this but
it was with fairly untrained people but
they
they used like pretty periodic weeks off
have you ever seen that research where
they compared continuous training versus
people who just like
trained for a little bit of time and
then just stayed away from the gym and
it was kind of like an intermittent
thing like that
yeah so there are actually a couple
studies on that uh the lead author for
for both of them is agus awara and
the way that those studies worked is
essentially
one group would just train continuously
and the other group would train
six weeks on three weeks off and those
three weeks off were just
three weeks off off um and what they
found
is is over a pretty reasonable length of
time i want to say one of the studies
ran 15 weeks and the other maybe
ran 21 weeks or something like that
the group taking periodic time off ended
up having similar strength gains
and similar hypertrophy to the group
training continuously
one thing to note is those studies were
on untrained lifters
so you know i i pro i don't think it's
probably ideal to take
a third of your time completely off
training if you're
10 years into the game and still trying
to make progress
uh but but i i do think it probably
illustrates that time completely off
isn't as deleterious as a lot of people
think it will be
especially when you're talking a one
week duration versus three i mean three
weeks off is a significant amount of
time off yeah
that's a long time yeah um but yeah like
a week
it's fine i i think i think lifting
becomes such a large part of people's
identities that
like taking a week out of the gym
completely is almost like
a threat to identity to a lot of people
and so
like they want to believe they're gonna
lose all of their gains
just so they can justify always going to
the gym
yeah uh but man yeah like and so i mean
like talking to clients they'll be like
hey i'm going on vacation
um i'm not sure that i'll be able to
find like a good gym near the hotel uh
like what should i do with my training
i'm like
dude like i can write you some workouts
that you can do in your vacation but
you're on vacation like just take time
off and they're like oh i can do that
like yes you can do that come on like
you take
two weeks off a year that's that's not
that's not gonna [ __ ] you up
yeah um so yeah like probably not
probably not theoretically optimal but
as long as you're not taking like a
quarter of your time
completely off of training by doing a
complete unload once
like one week out of every month it's
probably fine
and even if you did do that that would
probably be fine as well
we've talked about um we've talked about
john cole on the podcast before i'm
pretty sure
i think we've talked about him on here i
think so um so like the way he trained
is he worked out once per week uh
those workouts were like six to eight
hours long but he just trained
essentially all day every saturday and
not at all
uh sunday through friday so i mean
one could conceptualize that as
a six-day deload he took a week off
every week
he took yeah that's what he did he took
of of however many hours are in the week
he took that number of hours minus
six off between sessions you know yeah
and he was fine so yeah i mean i i don't
think you need to worry all that much
about missing a week of training
every now and again yeah i mean my
approach to d-loads is fairly similar
i would add one additional thing so you
talked about you know you could do your
uh proactive deloads that are kind of
scheduled
you know into the program day one you've
also got your reactive
deloads where you're like okay this i
can sense that it's probably time
i use something that i think you could
call a
prospective deload okay and what i mean
by that is
i i do enjoy traveling and i don't enjoy
training while traveling
because usually my workouts even if i
try to do them
they tend to suck and they
take away from time like if i'm in
london
i don't necessarily want to spend a
significant portion of that in a gym
unless it's like a
fitness trip where i'm working out with
fitness people then that's like a social
thing
more than a training thing but like if
i'm going somewhere to like see the
sights
i don't necessarily want to spend a huge
percentage of that trip in a gym
you know i want to go see the sites yeah
for sure and so what i'll do is
if i see that i've got those travel
dates in my calendar
i will program my training to basically
crescendo up into that
such that by the time i get to that trip
i
really need a week off so i'll almost
like intentionally plan to
overreach leaning into that trip
so you know if you're someone who gets a
little bit stressed out about taking a
week off or you want to make
sure that you know a week off isn't
necessarily optimal
but how do i make it less sub-optimal
that's one thing that i've done in the
past especially when i was really
ramping up my training like now i just
don't train ever because i suck
but but back then that was a strategy i
used that i actually liked a lot because
like
it it it essentially justified taking a
week off
i've also done that in the past if i
knew that i had a really crazy week
where i was like oh
that week has just deadlines all over it
i probably shouldn't spend eight hours
in a gym that week
that's going to be a deload and then
i'll work backwards from there and kind
of plan out my training accordingly